So now we know how to find the right bucket. Let's
look at how to define the add procedure. So we are going to
first define add, we'll make hashtable add, that takes a hashtable,
a word and a value. And first we'll define a simple version
of that, that says we are going to add the new entry
to the bucket even if it already exists. So we'll find the
right bucket. And we'll add the new entry at the end. So
your goal is to define a procedure, we'll call it hash table_add.
Takes three inputs: a hash table, a key, which is the
word, and a value, and it adds that key to the
hashtable, making sure to put it in the correct bucket with
the associated value that was passed in as the third input.